we came to the border to cover the
resumption of Aid into Northern Syria
but what we saw
was body bag after body bag being
carried towards the Border in the bag
behind clearly a small child
these are syrians who were killed in the
earthquake in Turkey
he makes space for more their families
sending them back home to be buried
the smell of death hangs thick in the
air here
few hours more than 50 bodies at least
no relative wanted to speak to us on
camera
but this is a grandmother and her two
grandchildren
a father came to bring his own children
look at them he told us clearly in a
daze the youngest is five the other is
twelve he said it looks like they are
sleeping
the bodies of four children are in that
vehicle and they're about to be put into
the truck to be taken across the border
they came here to flee war and had to
restart their lives all over again many
syrians decided to resettle here in
hatai province which is one of the areas
that's been hardest hit
the man holding the paperwork drives
them across the border into Syria he
also didn't want to talk on camera he
works 20-hour days he tells us
most syrians who fled the war will tell
you that they dream of one day finally
being able to return back home
but not like this
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera on the
Turkish Syrian border